president biden continues to walk a very
fine line in his response
to this latest middle east crisis while
he did tell israeli prime minister
benjamin netanyahu he supports a
ceasefire
he stopped short of demanding an end to
the attacks on gaza many people want him
to do exactly that
wishing reports now from the white house
president biden was bluntly asked if he
would insist on a ceasefire in gaza
given the escalation of violence i'll be
speaking with the prime minister in an
hour and i'll be able to talk to you
after that
later in a statement the white house
said the president reiterated his firm
support for israel's right to defend
itself
and express his support for a ceasefire
during his
third call with prime minister benjamin
netanyahu in less than a week
but reaching a ceasefire deal will
require help from partners in the region
such as egypt which talks directly to
hamas
something the u.s won't do because it
has designated the group
a terrorist organization but a growing
number of democrats want
less talk more action to push for an end
to the violence
i want to see a cease fire reach quickly
and mourn the loss
leaders have a different message
president biden must remain strong
against the growing voices within his
own party
that create false equivalence
between terrorist aggressors and
a responsible state defending itself
but critics say israel has crossed the
line of self-defense
pointing to the rising number of
civilian deaths
cbs news has learned that the u.s struck
a 735
million dollar deal to sell precision
guided weapons to israel before
all of this recent violence unfolded
several democrats are expressing concern
over the timing
congresswoman ilhan omar saying it would
be appalling to move forward with the
deal with no
strings attached the white house is not
commenting
anthony weija thank you